[Música]
bienvenidos a elecciones 2022 un tour
por francia te programa en que
analizamos los principales temas de la
campaña electoral francesa tomamos
dirección hacia el centro de francia
[Música]
y ponemos nuestras cámaras en el
departamento de la classe concretamente
en la pequeña ciudad de jr para conocer
cómo es vivir lejos de los grandes
centros urbanos
[Música]
nuevo no hay nada el médico no había de
domicilio tengo un problema de salud yo
tengo que ir a la farmacia para que no
pudo porque no tengo a uno del campo no
hay nada ni siquiera pasa el panadero
[Música]
no fue fácil encontrar respuestas o
apoyo cuando vives en un lugar tan
aislado
y
somos el departamento más viejo de
francia e incluso el más viejo de europa
a comienzos de los 2000 vimos en eso una
oportunidad
francés del país con mayor superficie de
la unión europea por lo que muchos de
sus electores viven en zonas rurales
pero a menudo se enfrentan a servicios
públicos escasos a una infraestructura
deficiente oa falta de trabajo
conozcamos más sobre esta diferencia
campo ciudad
en 2020 casi el 80 por ciento de los
franceses vivían en ciudades y casi 5 de
cada 10 personas en una ciudad de más de
100 mil habitantes
estos son los citadinos las zonas
rurales aglutinaban en cambio según los
mismos estudios entre el 20% y el 30% de
la población francesa sin embargo a
principios de la década de 1930 la
mayoría de la población vivía fuera de
la ciudad pero en 1945 se produjo un
fenómeno de éxodo rural y la población
del campo se vio diezmada desde 1975 la
proporción de habitantes urbanos se ha
disparado pero hay otro fenómeno los
suburbios los habitantes de las ciudades
establecen en zonas rurales aunque
mantienen un trabajo en la ciudad en
general las actividades del sector
terciario como el comercio el transporte
o las finanzas se concentran en las
ciudades donde el acceso a los mercados
y la formación es más fácil solo las
empresas de servicios a las personas
intentan sobrevivir en provincia en
provincia aunque los ingresos de los
habitantes provienen principalmente de
la producción local el número de
personas que trabajan en la agricultura
por ejemplo ha caído en un 12% en 10
años
muchos franceses sueñan con vivir en el
campo y sobre todo después de los
confinamientos es lo que dicen las
encuestas pero la falta de servicios
básicos y el miedo a sentirse aislados
son un freno a la hora de tomar la
decisión
cada vez más gente como yo que da el
paso y estamos felices de vivir en zonas
rurales en ciudades pequeñas o medianas
es más confortable y la calidad de vida
es mejor así que tengo todo lo que
necesito al igual que los problemas
ligados del poder adquisitivo encuentro
que es un tema que tiene su lugar en el
debate está bien que todo el plan de
datos no importa su tendencia hablen del
tema
[Música]
en esta campaña electoral no hablamos
suficientemente de las zonas rurales y
las directrices tomadas por las zonas
urbanas no están adaptadas a nuestras
zonas rurales en particular en lo que
respecta al transporte
quieto
el médico a domicilio
si tengo un problema
en el campo
22 habitantes por kilómetro cuadrado esa
es la densidad del departamento de la
creuse el segundo menos poblado de
francia aquí cada año las ciudades
pierden habitantes para entender cómo es
la vida aquí conversamos con eric o veía
presidente de la aglomeración de 25
comunas del gran que región
el corre ya cuáles son los desafíos para
hacer vivir un departamento como la
acción de pacific tenemos varios
desafíos primero el desafío demográfico
necesitamos atraer personas porque creo
que es una necesidad que no podemos
seguir asignando a la población en
grandes centros urbanos de ser que la
gente sea feliz el segundo es un desafío
económico al propietario de un negocio
tal vez sea más fácil establecerse en
los suburbios periféricos de burdeos por
ejemplo
porque el mercado está justo al lado en
lugar de venir a la cruz donde
necesitara pagar el transporte
y un tercer reto es el de la
infraestructura del transporte aunque
tenemos carreteras concretamente la
carretera nacional aún no tenemos acceso
al ferrocarril
y eso es un verdadero problema para
nuestros territorios
porque mañana con la transición
ecológica en marcha tendremos que usar
cada vez menos el coche y cada vez más
el transporte público sino un hito para
sepa posible la juventud encuentra
dificultades muchos parten cada año cómo
hacer para que se queden a vivir allí
creo que cuando uno es joven y vive en
un territorio rural como éste no es
anormal querer irse y ver otros lugares
pienso que quizás el problema de la
gente del agua es que estamos un poco
encerrados en nuestras cabezas nos
quedamos en nuestros territorios sin ver
lo que ocurría en otros lugares y la
crisis no es una isla entonces si los
jóvenes quieren irse está muy bien
también hemos desarrollado las
universidades en este territorio es
importante evitar la fuga de cerebros
porque los jóvenes son también materia
gris además pueden irse pero luego
volver así que nosotros tenemos que
crear las condiciones para que si desean
regresar con un proyecto de vida estemos
listos para recibirlos y ayudarlos a
realizar ese proyecto hablamos de la
juventud pero también las personas
mayores se encuentran problemas como es
envejecer en hiere y
envejecer aquí es quizás mejor que en
otras partes justamente porque somos el
departamento más viejo de francia e
incluso el más viejo de europa a
comienzos de los 2000 vimos en eso una
oportunidad al servicio del desarrollo
económico local así nació la domótica y
la autonomía es decir como automatizar
una vivienda para prolongar la vida de
las personas mayores el mayor tiempo
posible en condiciones de seguridad y
que no se aíslen porque una persona
aislada es una persona vulnerable
entonces trabajamos sobre la automática
y automatizamos los domicilios creamos
también un centro especializado en la
domótica en la ciudad en que estamos
aumentando la vivienda del mañana una
casa que evoluciona a lo largo de la
vida supongamos que usted es una joven
pareja usted sola se instala en una casa
pero a medida que envejecemos nos
enfermamos y este lugar no está adaptado
a nuestras necesidades trabajamos mucho
sobre el lugar de vida y eso puede hacer
que envejecer en la cruz sea mejor y
menos solitario que en otros sitios
el 2021 la ciudad de quiere propuso una
ayuda de 10 mil euros a las personas
para instalarse es que este tipo de
iniciativas son útiles qué resultados
han dado
casting de solución mst de ley tiene 11
efe esta es una de las soluciones fue
lanzada haya una asociación entre el
estado la alcaldía en la gobernación
porque el corazón de la ciudad está
sufriendo
en una época hubo muchas viviendas
sociales y muchas casas vacías
necesitamos hacer venir a las familias
al corazón de las ciudades para que
vivan y consuma de allí así mantenemos
el tejido comercial en el centro de las
ciudades
creemos que esta ayuda puede atraer
familias jóvenes con niños que mañana
podrán habitar y rehabilitar barrios y
hacer vivir el tejido comercial y así en
vez de tener periferias con grandes
centros comerciales instalaremos
comercios en el corazón de la ciudad eso
es lo importante
muchas gracias quédese con ella gracias
ubicado
[Música]
franz es un pilar fundamental de la
agricultura de la unión europea a quien
lejos representa un 10 por ciento de los
ingresos de sus ciudadanos sin embargo
estos agricultores temen que su
actividad se extinga para abrirse a
nuevas oportunidades muchos se han
convertido al bío en reportajes de
caridad la puja
como cada mañana a philippe bovy leen y
a las vacas por el campo hace 20 años su
cuñado y socio falleció de cáncer y el
tomo su lugar
yo él tenía un hermano que falleció
debido a un cáncer lúcido por los
pesticidas en esa época las personas no
hablaban de eso pero su médico dijo que
no habían dudas y los pesticidas saben
lo causar por esto nosotros decidimos
detenerlos estamos dañando nos dañando a
otros no podíamos con almuerzo
philip y su pareja tienen 80 vacas ellos
ahorran costos alimentándolas con heno y
granos procedentes de su granja la carne
orgánica se vende un 20% más alto pero
los precios no se han movido en agente
el precio de venta desde hace 30 años ha
sido casi el mismo la política europea
de agricultura se creó para respaldar
los precios nosotros preferiríamos tener
menos ayudas y vender nuestra carne
philip y su esposa de joel reciben un
salario mínimo alrededor de 1200 euros
por mes pasar al mercado orgánico no ha
sido simple
con una verificación
difícil a veces teníamos preguntas sobre
todo al principio
no fue fácil encontrar respuestas o
apoyo cuando vives en un lugar tan
aislado o ser un certamen de actividad
en dos años filippi joel se jubilarán y
su hija elsa junto con su familia se
harán cargo de la granja
no sabemos cuántos animales seguirán y
lo estamos analizando
mencionado gente
con tan mágicas
amamos nuestro trabajo pero cuando
alcanza cierta edad quiere ir más
tranquilo
si nuestra familia no se hubiera hecho a
cargo de la granja nos hubiera tocado
venderla esto nos parece mejor
desde hace 5 años elsa los apoya para
plantar hortalizas
que luego vende y distribuye en
restaurantes locales y escuelas
y yo con tintes de guillermo nosotros yo
reparto regularmente para dos escuelas
ahora otra escuela está interesada
estoy muy feliz y orgullosa
sí
claude pareja de elsa trabaja cada
viernes en el mercado aún tiene otro
trabajo pero espera dejarlo para
centrarse en la granja
[Música]
y hasta aquí este capítulo de elecciones
2022 un tour por francia tomamos ahora
dirección hacia el departamento de la
sonda en el sudoeste de francia gracias
por su preferencia
[Música]